[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact it's built by
insects but you can see it from space
because it's so big scientists have
recently discovered a grouping of over
200 million ancient termite mounds in
northeastern Brazil covering in an area
larger than Great Britain the termite
mounds many still active today are
massive some over ten feet tall and
thirty feet across the hills are the
result of a giant species of termites
that have been piling up the dirt as
they dig their underground tunnels over
a period of four thousand years the
mounds easily seen with satellite images
I even took a look tonight on Google
Earth have previously been hidden under
trees that are now being cleared to
create grazing land over millennia
it's believed these bugs have excavated
enough soil to create four thousand
great pyramids of giza making this the
largest insect engineered ecosystem on
the planet it's incredible what a big
difference a little creature can make
with persistence you know the Bible says
with a little faith you can move
mountains stay where those friends were
going to learn more on this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 streaming on
the internet and you can watch it on
facebook at the doug batchelor facebook
page or the amazing facts Facebook page
and that number once again to call in
with your questions reef own call 800
for six three seven two nine seven
that's 800 god says
800 four six three seven 297 my name is
Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and pastor Doug is we
always do let's start the program with
prayer dear father we thank you that we
have this opportunity to once again open
up your word and study these very
important truths found in Scripture
life-changing truths and we ask your
blessing upon our time together I pray
that you'd be with those listening and
guide us as we search for Bible truth
fully assets in Jesus name Amen amen
Oh pastor Doug you think of termites and
they often a curse but you know
specially when it comes to being in
people's homes but he have a whole
colony of these little termites that set
their mind to moving dirt and boy did
they move dirt yeah you can actually see
pictures of this on the internet and I I
went on as I mentioned Google Earth and
I look
from space and you really can't see it
in the satellite images it's just it
looks like freckles all over this
section of a northeastern Brazil then
you see the ground pictures and they've
just been piling up the dirt they don't
live in the mounds this is the the
leftovers from the tunnels that they dig
and they collect leaves and they live
off that but they basically build
mountains someone said once how does an
auntie tin elephant and of course the
answer is one bite at a time and even
Jesus taught this principle what a big
difference a little thing can make he
said in mark chapter four verse 32 what
shall we like in the kingdom of heaven
or with what parable shall we picture it
it's like a mustard seed which when it
is sown it's smaller than all the seeds
of the earth but when it is sown it
grows up and becomes greater than all of
the herbs and it shoots out large
branches so the birds of the air might
nest in its shade now you and I were in
Israel well last year mm-hmm around this
time down by Caesarea they showed us
some mustard plants I don't know if you
were standing with this one I did and
and yeah they grow into pretty big
shrubs and it comes from an itsy bitsy
almost microscopic seed and Jesus saying
if you've got a little faith like that
you can move mountains now Christ isn't
telling us that we need mountain-moving
faith because he wants us to give
caterpillar some competition the Lord is
saying we need mountain-moving faith
because we all are being crushed under a
mountain of guilt and sin but through
faith in Jesus we can have forgiveness
we can have assurance that God will
forgive our sins and we have a book that
we'd like to share with you for free how
can you know how can you have that
saving mountain-moving faith and know
that your sins are forgiven a book
tonight a free offer is called assurance
it's called justification made simple
how you can know that you can receive
the promised forgiveness that God wishes
to give we'll be happy to send this
anyone who calls an ass the number to
call these eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and just ask
for the book called assurance written by
pastor Doug and I'm sure you'll find
this a blessing again that number is 885
six seven four seven and if you have a
Bible question our phone
I'm here to the studio is 804 6 3 7 2 9
7 again that number is 804 63 72 97
that'll bring you right here into the
studio with your Bible question and
tonight our first call is Chris
listening in Florida Chris welcome to
the program hello Chris your question
tonight um okay it's um it's Exodus 3:14
16 it says in Exodus 3:14 and God said
to Moses I am Who I am and he said thus
you shall say to the children of Israel
I am has sent me to you
moreover God said to Moses thus you
shall say to the children of Israel the
Lord God of your father's the God of
Abraham the god of Isaac and the God of
Jacob has sent me to you this is my name
forever and this is my memorial to all
generations so your question about that
verse so my question is why how do you
explain how do you understand the answer
of God to Moses that he said I am Who I
am and then in the New Testament let's
say in the Matthew 6:9 when Jesus talks
to oppose apostles apostles how to pray
he tells them to call God our Father
well God goes by many titles the Bible
tells us that not only is God identify
now first of all the reason that God
told Moses go tell the Egyptians I am
that I am that that phrase there I am
means the self-existent one the
Egyptians had many gods they were
polytheistic and they had all these
stories behind their different gods and
the gods were fighting among each other
and God said look I am I've not been
made by another God I am the one who is
eternal and this is why the Jews
actually wanted to some of the religious
leaders wanted to stone Jesus when he
said before Abraham was I am so even one
of the titles that Christ took for
himself as the self-existent one but
that's not the only name God is also
called the Alpha
he's called Elohim he's called the Lord
Almighty God probably has about 40
different titles he uses in the Bible to
identify himself so to call him our
Father in heaven is certainly
appropriate so can I ask a question in
what do the Jews call the God the Father
our Father of their ancestors well in
many cases the Jews called God the
father of Abraham Isaac and Jacob I
think even in the Old Testament says
have we not one father and so they
sometime use the word father to refer to
God there's nothing wrong with using
that title and of course Jesus took that
one he shared the Lord's Prayer now I
have a book I'd like to send you a free
copy Chris and it's called the name of
God and all you got to do is call we'll
send this to you and I go in-depth there
it's kind of a deep study when you start
talking about all the Hebrew and even
some Greek titles but I have a book
there that goes into more detail you'll
enjoy the number to call knees 808 three
five six seven four seven and as for the
book called the name of God were happy
to send it to anyone who calls and ask
that number again is eight hundred eight
thirty five sixty seven forty seven
we've got Robin listening from st.
John's in Michigan Robin welcome to the
program Robin are you on the air Robin
might have her mute on hi good your
question um I've heard most gelatin is
made from pig skins and unused other
parts and this is in all kinds of foods
gummy worms marshmallows various candy
what is your personal stance on this is
a food substance
well I Fran for fortunately I don't like
gelatin one of these people that never
cared for jell-o I I'd like my food to
stand still when I'm eating it and if
it's still moving I don't eat it but
yeah you know if if it's they do have
artificial or what do you call it
they've got vegetarian based gelatin and
obviously that would be okay I would
avoid animal product gelatin you know
some people will argue that by the time
the the food companies make gelatin from
the
yes if I heard is actually made from
some of the hoof parts bones and skin
yeah that it has been so highly
processed that it's basically a chemical
at that point because it's been refined
and broken down but I want to want to
eat that anyway
I don't eat gummy bears jelly beans
anyway but yeah it's true
some some gelatin is made from animal
by-products and I I don't care for it
is this something biblically that we
should stay away from yeah you know that
depends like I said they're not all
gelatin is made the same way the Bible
forbids eating anything that comes from
an unclean animal and clean animals
would be you know the pigs and and
camels course nobody makes gelatin from
camels I don't think but they probably
do use hog parts in some gelatin but
then you kind of have to dig and
research I don't know what they say on
the labels they've got some kind of
clever way of wording it yeah sometimes
it specifies if it's you know beef or
whatnot but I've heard that 90% plus is
made from pig products you know and the
majority that is skin so I'm just
wondering like should I be nitpicky
about it or well if you know what the
Bible says if it's not of faith it's sin
so if you got any doubts I would turn my
back on those gummy bears and I won't I
told you I won't eat him so yeah yeah
yeah no I appreciate that and most
people don't know cuz as I said the
packaging it doesn't come out and say
made from animal parts or what what
animal parts yeah some things are made
from byproducts you know we do have a
study guide talking about what the Bible
says about health and I think folks will
find this very informative
it's called God's free health plan it's
one of the amazing facts study guides
and we'll be happy to send this for free
to anyone who calls and ask the number
is 883 five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the study guide called God's
free health plan want to know God's plan
for our world and solutions for your
life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide in Korea
based answers to questions on healthier
relationships when Jesus will return and
much more refer to watch while you read
our brand new prophecy encounters DVD
series makes the perfect companion set
order your study guides and DVDs today
by visiting AAF bookstore comm or by
calling 858 seven two seven five four
life-changing Christian resources this
@af bookstore comm Mexico Lee is Andrea
and Andrea welcome to the program thank
you god bless both of you for all you do
well thank you so much and your question
I have a question I need to know who is
the Antichrist is it Satan or is it
another person well know right away that
Satan is behind the Antichrist just like
you know all the fullness of God and the
Spirit of God was embodied in Jesus that
anyone who is playing the part of the
Antichrist has the spirit of the devil
so you don't have to question that now
will the will the devil be operating
through human agencies that are
possessed or being controlled by Haman
and I think yes that's happened in the
past I mean even the high priest that
condemned Jesus was a religious leader
that was demon-possessed really he was
willing to kill Christ at any cost so in
the last days we'll have more of that
you know I think first thing you need to
note that the word Antichrist does not
always mean standing in opposition to
Christ it could also mean taking the
place of Christ so when you think of the
Antichrist power that the Bible speaks
of in the last days you're not only
looking for a power that he's standing
in opposition to Christ but very often
it is those who claim to be Christ's
followers religious leaders that might
be moved by a selfish or jealous spirit
who are standing in opposition to the
teachings of the Bible so the Bible says
even the devil himself can be
transformed into an angel of light now
we do have a study guide called who is
the Antichrist and it's quite an
eye-opening study it gets right into
Revelation chapter 13
that is a free offer that we'll be happy
to send to anyone who asks just you'll
just give us a call and we'll be happy
to send that out to anyone called who is
the Antichrist the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and as for the
study guide again called who is the
Antichrist thank you appreciate your
call Michael find out what the critics
are raving about top scholars and
theologians from around the country come
together to reveal the hidden history of
the book of Revelation with powerful
reenactments and incredible visual
effects this 95 minute masterpiece
brings to life the book of Revelation
like never before revelation is no
longer a mystery get your copy today
visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
next Cola that we have is actually now
we have Michael I think Michael
listening in Michigan Michael welcome to
the program hello can you hear me yes
sir
good guys I'm on speakerphone so level
I'm trying to tips it out yeah I have a
question a really good question mean
just a couple of hours ago me and my dad
were talking about it and I'm the one to
bring it up and I don't know of any
Bible text 11 what happens to a angel
when a person passes away
are there any Bible like Bible text
explained you mean like there's a
guardian angel become unemployed is that
what you're asking
no when a port when a person passes away
does God get him a new position in
another Oh hug it there's no universe
does he assign him another another human
to guard does he find his job basically
cuz I was talking about my I was talking
to my dad about this and he said I don't
know maybe God gave him another position
in heaven or he puts them in another
world and saying you know in this
universe I'm well I don't know as you
know the Bible tells us that God God
does have angels that watch over people
yeah it says in Psalm 91 he'll give his
angels charge over you to keep you and
Christ tells us that the angels of
children behold the face of your father
in heaven so we do believe there are
angels assigned to watch over people
Satan probably has angels assigned to
tempt people and study their weaknesses
I think CS Lewis brings that out in his
book the Screwtape Letters what happens
when a person dies with those angels the
Bible really I don't know of any comment
that's made on that you would assume if
I'm looking Matthew chapter 18 verse 10
where it says take heed that you do not
despise one of these little ones for a
sound to you that in heaven their angels
always see the face of my father so one
would assume that if the child grows up
and becomes an adult and eventually
passes away the angel seems to be
assigned to another child to watch you
do have the angel Gabriel who is sent to
different individuals after
one died so you've got Gabriel talking
to Daniel after Daniel dies Gabriel
talks to Mary so it's not like angels
are just you know treading water until
the resurrection I think God keeps him
involved absolutely the Bible speaks of
angels has been ministering spirits sent
out to those who are to inherit
salvation I'm trying to think we've got
that book on angel messages yes that's
one of our amazing facts study guides
called angel messages from outer space
talks about angels but it also talks
about the Gospel as we find in the Bible
then I'm going to call these 808 three
five six seven four seven and ask for
the study guide it's entitled angel
messages and we'll be happy to send that
out to anyone who asks if you have a
Bible question our number here in the
studio is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven next one of the
behalf is garden a listening from New
York gardener welcome to the program
thank you you may want to turn your
radio down oh I wanted to know the
scripture of the washing of the feet I
guess most people would guess that it's
there to teach us humility or maybe
service to others is that true is there
something else that we should derive
from that scripture and should that
activity be incorporated in a church
service to speak or what are we to learn
from that scripture and should we be
doing that alright well it's interesting
that there's a couple of Rights that
Jesus established one is of course the
communion service and the other one
would would be a baptism part of the
communion service when you read in John
he washed their feet and then they had
the Lord's Supper together after Jesus
washed their feet he said you should do
as I have done to you and you read this
in John chapter 13 and you go to verse
so twelve he says do you know what I've
done you call me Lord and teacher and
you say well four so I am if I then your
Lord and teacher have washed your feet
you ought to also wash one another's
feet for I have given you an example
that you should do as I have done to you
now several Christian denominations
seventh-day Adventists primitive
Baptists and others
they still practice this a lot of some
churches do it maybe once a year I think
even the Catholic Church the Pope washes
people's feet once a year because even
they see it in the Bible I do think it's
something that we do and to commemorate
the act of service of Jesus humbling
himself and washing the disciples feet
you know a person's feet it's like the
lowest part of your body and it's a sign
of I'm willing to serve and take a
little position I think that's important
still well thank you for your answer I
just want to say before I hang up in my
lifetime it seems like people who are
sabbath-keeping ministries are the least
likely to take advantage of people
financially I just want to make that
statement oh well guys I appreciate that
thank you very much yeah we certainly we
try not to exploit anybody and and we
figure it's God that moves on folks
hearts to to give and support a ministry
next caller that we have is Stephanie
listening from Albuquerque New Mexico
Stephanie welcome to the program hi
thank you how are you tonight great we
appreciate your calling and your
question thanks okay so I'm currently
reading a book called the strategy of
Satan how to detect and defeat him and
within the first chapter 2 there is a
sentence that says positionally we are
seated with Christ and delivered from
the power of Satan quoting Colossians
1:13 for he rescued us from the domain
of darkness and transferred us into the
kingdom of his beloved son and then the
next sentence it says Satan enjoys
seeing Christians get ahead knowledge of
victory without a heart experience so my
question is I'm struggling in that area
for years I've been saying that there's
some kind of disconnect between my head
and my heart that I know in one place
that I've been forgiven and I know in
one place that I can trust and I know in
one place that I can believe but in the
other place there's doubt so how do I
have
I must obviously have the head knowledge
how do I get the heart experience
well faith and what we talked about
tonight the book that we're providing
will help you with that and it's free
you know the Lord is very clear that if
we repent of our sins if we turn from
our sins confess our sins he promises
that he is faithful and just to forgive
us and to cleanse us from all of our
unrighteousness so if we believe what
His Word says and if we do what he's
asking us to do then you know Jesus said
if we repent the kingdom of heaven is at
hand he at hand means within reach he'd
be you know we give Him leadership of
our hearts and we say Lord I believe in
you I'm gonna do your word I'm gonna
follow your will and Jesus said you know
it's not just saying Lord Lord it's not
just a hidden knowledge but it's a heart
knowledge he said it's those who are
willing to do the commandments of my
father the Lord wants us to be
transformed in life not just in our mind
you know Stephanie I think you really
enjoy the book that we offering tonight
for free and it deals with this very
subject scold assurance justification
made simple how can we by faith claim
the promise of God not only the promise
of forgiveness but we also need God's
grace and strength to live a victorious
Christian life and that's addressed in
the book called assurance if you'd like
to receive it the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again just ask for the
book called assurance we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who calls and asks
we have nichts listening in Michigan
Nick welcome to the program hi guys hi
how are you doing I'm doing fine
I really appreciate um my question is
how should I approach someone who
doesn't think that God is really
necessary in their life like this they
feel like they're doing fine without
them well first of all you can't make
somebody it'd be great if we knew a
formula to make all the lost out there
suddenly realized they need to turn to
the Lord we do our best and evangelism
and the way that we go about that is try
to get people to think all right I know
I have a limited time to live do you
know I'd ask a person do you realize
you're not going to live long yeah now
if there's a possibility that people
receive
eternal rewards for their behavior why
would you want to just say well I don't
care what happens or I don't know
whatever happens happens why would you
gamble with the opportunity of living
forever or being lost forever
and that is worth looking into I've
heard many of you Angeles say now if you
should die tonight what would happen to
you then
and sometimes that arrests people's
attention they go well uh you know I
don't know whatever yeah you know it's
really dumb to take it whatever approach
to your eternity you know you might be
as bold as to ask them that kind of
question
you still there Nick yeah thank you yeah
absolutely you know I'm wondering if we
have a book on that or we do have some
of course evangelistic training that's a
whole course that we offer and how do
you lead a person to Christ don't want
to be a bad idea to put something like
that together in a book yeah you know
Nick this is not something we can offer
for free but we do have a book called
amazing disciples talking about how do
we share our faith with others and it's
not very expensive but it is something
that we'd be happy to make available to
you all you'll need to do just go to the
amazing facts website and look up
something called amazing disciples
it's a 13-part training program that
helps people share their faith and again
just go to the amazing facts website and
you'll be able to get more information
about that okay I said like we're
looking at the time we're coming up on a
mid program break we might not have
enough time to take a another caller hey
friends give us 60 seconds we're gonna
come up on the break in the meantime I
just want to remind you that all week
long amazing facts is doing what we're
doing right now we have programs on
television and then we're on radio of
course with this program and others and
sometimes this program is airing not
live but it's airing throughout the week
wanted us give a shout out to our
friends listening on strong tower radio
in Michigan that we get a lot of folks
that are listening during the week to
their recorded versions of the program
and if you want to you can actually go
to the amazing back YouTube page we are
uploading
new sermons almost every week some given
in different parts of the world of
evangelistic messages Bible teaching and
all you have to do is type in amazing
facts dot o-r-g that's amazing fax to RG
we also have a bookstore and at the
bookstore and that's the amazing facts
bookstore I've got a plethora a
kaleidoscope a blizzard of Bible study
and personal growth materials so check
us out at the amazing facts bookstore
more questions coming in just a moment
give us a call
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
does your heart burns for a better
purpose do you yearn to do more with
your faith do you desire to be a
powerful witness a blaze for Jesus
Christ where do you start make your
first step at eff go the amazing fact
center of evangelism here at Affco i've
learned so many things in my spiritual
growth has just skyrocketed
asko has distilled fifty years of
amazing facts evangelistic expertise
into a dynamic professional and
educational experience that transforms
the nervous christian into a prepared
and bold witness Affco is really about
learning while doing it's a
one-of-a-kind experience for those who
are serious about entering gospel
ministry and those who simply want to
make an impact in their local churches
and communities go to ask org today and
explore this life-changing program Affco
equipping soul-winners setting the world
ablaze for god written by the hand of
god and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 877-709-7899 or visit AF
bookstore com every bible question you
have answered moves you one step closer
to the fullness of God's will for your
life so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 Bible answers
live
thank you brother is glad to be here
thanks for calling in your question
first time you shout out a happy
birthday to you dude oh well thank you
mom'll be sixty to myself in about three
weeks so how well I guess now you you
you outed me everybody knows how old I
am
oh you make it look good anyway hey my
question uh my question was a in assists
in 3:15 God talks about
in this seed of the woman and also Moses
is God to raise up a prophet like me and
Deuteronomy 18 but they were quite
question is welcome God never mentioned
never causing my son he never says I'm
sending my son in the Old Testament
not until Nebuchadnezzar there's only
one that identifies him as a son of God
I just wondering why he never you know
said he was ascending I'm sending my son
well you know I think there are some
there are some allegories in the stories
of the Bible that make it clear it's his
son like when Abraham offered Isaac his
son yeah and he says you know you've not
withheld your son from me and the
implication is al not withhold my son
from the world and then you got David
Nathan the Prophet says the David your
son will build me a house that will last
forever which is you know kind of a
prophecy or it's not kind of it is it's
a prophecy of Jesus who he said destroy
this temple made with hands and I'll
make one without hands he built the
house of the Lord so I think there there
are analogies and references and hints
of Jesus being the Son of God even in
the Old Testament he's often referred to
as the branch of David he's called the
seed he's called the servant there's a
number of names that Jesus in his pre
incarnation is referred to in the Old
Testament prophecies he's called
wonderful counselor mighty God
everlasting father Prince of Peace you
know in Isaiah chapter it was a nine six
so I don't know if I'm answering your
question though Stephen yeah pretty much
I mean he finally says you know this is
my beloved son in the New Testament but
I was just one of mine ever said you
know I'm sending my son you know even
Moses said God's gonna raise up a
prophet like me but I thought he was
much greater than Moses but you know I
just wanted everybody allegory does
there's gonna say that well I think
Moses said that Jesus that the Lord was
going to raise up a prophet like Moses
and that Christ was a meteor as Moses
was a mediator between the people in God
Moses died before they entered the
promised land Christ had to die Moses
was born from slaves but he never served
as a slave Jesus was born from people
who sin but he never sinned and so
there's a lot of allegories of even
Moses to Jesus when you start looking at
them I've got a book that
it's not one of our free books but you
it talks a lot about this and it's
caught what we do for the book name of
God but I've got a book called shadows
of light seeing Christ in all the
scripture that that talks about this
principle and apply
it's called shadows of light if you just
type in Doug Batchelor shadows of light
of Life yeah and or we'll send you a
free copy of that book the names of God
again the number to call for that is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and asked for our free offer
this evening it's called or the book is
called the names of God and we'll be
happy to send it again to anyone who
calls and asks deep within the pages of
the Bible stories of great heroes heroes
of great deeds great love and great
sacrifice but behind them is another
hero hidden in plain sight amid the
shadows he was there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry shadows of light seeing Jesus
in all the Bible get your copy today by
calling 855-578-6767 able to improve on
it he said there are three things there
really only three things you can do to
reach the people you love and he said
those three things are powerful things
but there's only three things one is you
pray for them and you know sometimes
people say what and you just pray that's
all I can do well prayer is very
powerful
if you pray in faith the Bible says a
fervent effectual prayer of a righteous
man avails much so if anyone listening
if you want to reach loved ones brothers
sister children parents anybody friends
pray for them and I do the other is if
if they're open share information with
them means pray for them then hand them
an amazing fax the DVD hand them a book
oh that good devotional that will talk
about Christ or inspire them or
something they might read might be a
testimony so share information and then
the third thing is be a good example let
them see how Christ has made you happy
and change your life share your personal
testimony with them those are the three
things I can't think of anything outside
of those three things yeah well yeah and
you know and that's the you know I guess
that would be the fourth thing keep
doing it so you need persistence as a
Christian you need patience and
persistence even Jesus had to spend
three years working with the disciples
it takes a while to train people and a
very good hey thank you so much Pattie
and appreciate your your call tonight
and yeah we got to write that book on
how to reach you the Lost yeah next one
of the gravity's wand on listening in
California wonder welcome to the program
thank you Pastor John Ross and pastor
Doug how are you tonight doing great
and how can we help you tonight good
okay I know that God can read our
thoughts in our minds and angels right
in the books so does that mean that the
Angels also can read our thoughts in our
heart no there is a verse in I believe
it's 2nd Kings chapter 8 and pastor Ross
might look it up I think it's 39 but
second Kings 839 Solomon in his
dedication prayer he says God and God
only knows the thoughts of men's hearts
and that would mean angels don't know
now when angels are writing angels are
recording our works the Bible says that
we are judge according to our works that
are found in the books and so angels can
see what we do I don't believe angels
know what we think it's only God that
can really read our hearts
I don't think good angels can read our
minds any more than bad angels now a
devil can tempt us by putting a thought
in our mind and a good angel can try and
encourage us by putting a thought in our
mind you know just I can I can put a
thought in my wife's mind by whispering
in her ear so I mean anyone can put a
thought in someone else's mind all they
got to do is you know angels don't use
our ears as something inner that they do
but I don't think they can read our
minds
now of course angels I'm sure very
skilled they've had a lot of experience
in in reading our body language the
whole life so they know you know when
and where to kind of tempt a person and
where every person's weaknesses are I
think the verse we referring today is
1st Corinthians 29 18 our chronicles
sorry first Chronicles it might be in
both Chronicles and kings but I think
it's in okay I think it's in first Kings
chapter 8 it's a dedication prayer of
Solomon
you might try 38 or 39 if I remember
correctly but yeah they're basically
what he says for God and God only knows
the thoughts of men's hearts okay will
you answered it in mark chapter 2 Jesus
it says he knew what they were thinking
do you find that there anywhere I may
have guessed all wrong might be might be
yeah no now we're determined we're on a
mission now we want to find that verse
well well this really answers a huge
question because a group of us are in a
Bible study and the answer to that was
that they could and it was supposed to
have come from the testimonies for the
church but we were questioning it and
that's why I thought I would call into
you guys since you're so learning in the
Bible that you would be able to come up
with a scripture for me yeah it is first
it is first Kings chapter 8 verse 39 he
says for you alone know the hearts of
all the sons of men okay awesome thank
you all right hey thank you so much
appreciate your call okay god bless god
bless next caller that we have is Rachel
listening from Wisconsin Rachel welcome
to the program
thank you so my question is equally a
stealer in verse 7 says go eat your food
with gladness and drink your wine with
the joyful
heart regardez already approved what you
do and then in first Timothy 3 verse 8
it says deacons likewise must see men of
dignity not double-tongued or addicted
it is too much wine so my question is if
someone just you know reading the Bible
taking it um at what it says it kind of
appears that maybe a little bit like
socially drinking would be ok so I'm
just wondering what your thoughts are on
that
[Music]
I believe that Christians should not
drink any alcohol there's a with the
word wine appears through the Bible you
don't find the word grape juice anywhere
in the Bible many times when you find
the word wine it is referring to non
fermented sometimes it is fermented you
need to read the context I won't deny
that there were Bible characters and
kings it did drink wine but Solomon's
also the one who wrote in what is it
proverbs 22 wine is a mocker strong
drink is raging whoever's deceived
thereby is not wise and then Solomon
says another chapter in Proverbs who has
whoa who has wounds without a cause and
he talks about those who tarry at the
wine so you look at the Chronicle in the
Bible and you know Noah
he drank wine and he stumbled around
naked and it ended up being a curse on
one of the family Lots daughter's got
him to drink wine so that he would sleep
with his own daughters and commit incest
David tried to get Uriah to drink wine
so he would go against his conscience
the Bible says give wine to him he was
ready to perish when they gave Jesus
wine on the cross once he tasted what it
was he turned away and would not drink
it so he didn't want to cloud his senses
and sin I think when you look at the
suffering in society from alcohol and
considering that it is one of the most
addictive drugs more people are
alcoholics than almost any other drug I
mean we hear about the opioid crisis and
the heroin problems and all the other
addictive drugs fact is that more people
are addicted to alcohol than all of the
others put together and the hospitals
the accidents on the roads and it goes
on and on
I don't think Christians should
underwriter
support that or endorse it by our
example no and I fully agree with that
stance but I was just wondering for
someone who is not a drunk who uses it
quote/unquote responsibly and has you
know maybe not even a glass a day but
maybe once or twice a week you know if
it was you know talking about grape
juice why would in that verse would say
you know don't the addicted it too much
I mean that implies that a little bit is
okay well if keep in mind the Bible says
don't do anything that'll make your
brothers stumble now I actually passed
through the Church of Native Americans
in New Mexico where every member of my
church was born a potential alcoholic
when the Navajos drink and I'm not being
degrading they all know this is true
biologically if a Navajo starts drinking
they will become an alcoholic and if
they knew that I only drink once a week
and they tried to do it I might be able
to control it I used to drink wine but I
stopped because I didn't want to be a
bad witness and cause anyone else's life
to get messed up I saw too many people
that couldn't control it one out of
seven people the drinks becomes a
problem drinker and so how much does a
Christian by his example want to
encourage another person I mean it's not
like there's nothing to drink you go to
go to the supermarket about 50 things
you can pick off the shelf that don't
have alcohol you gotta watch for
caffeine these days you won't walk out
drunk you go out hopping you know we do
have a book called
alcohol and the Christian actually deals
with these different passages of
Scripture but looks at the subject as a
whole what does the Bible teach on that
and we'll be happy to send that to you
Rachel or anyone who might want to learn
more about it again the number to call
is 883 five six seven four seven and
just asked for the book alcohol and the
Christian yeah and just one closing
thought Rachel if you're still listening
yeah we do freely admit there are
examples in the Bible where some of the
patriarchs probably drank alcohol that
had started to ferment they didn't have
numbers on their wine skins back then
that's at 2% 5% 10% just as it got old
it started to swell the wine skins which
is why Jesus had you put the
wine and new wineskins keeps it new
longer you put new wine and old wine
skin it immediately begins to ferment
and swell the Bible records all kinds of
things that patriarchs did not because
it endorses it but because the Bible
gives a faithful record some of the
patriarchs had multiple wives while we
would endorse that today so the ideal
given in the Bible is don't do anything
that's going to cause another person to
stumble wine is a mocker strong drink is
raging don't be deceived by it it'll
bite like an adder and a serpent the
Bible says so that's our advice is to
stick with a teetotaling next photo that
we have that means David listening in
Sacramento California David welcome to
the program hello hi David welcome
you're on the air are we doing tonight
Doug oh doing great appreciate your
calling my question is kind of geared
toward the onset that we've seen over
the last few weeks with this push for
the one world religion worries me a lot
because in my belief of Jesus Christ
being the one and only Son of God how
are we going to have you know your
different religions of the world come
together and that be the the one God
that everybody will be worshipping well
fear does amazing things first of all
don't worry Jesus said don't be anxious
about anything and he told the disciples
fear not
and once you've committed your life to
the Lord if you fear God you don't have
to fear anything else but I just I
posted something on my Facebook page
last night someone had you know sent me
a news update about all the leaders of
the Mormon Church met for the first time
ever were they all met outside the
country they went to the Vatican where
they met with the Pope and they they
started I guess they were inaugurating
one of their largest temples in Rome of
all places and it's just been amazing to
me how Pope Francis has been so
successful in bringing all these
different religions to the table you
know Orthodox Russian Orthodox Greek
Orthodox Mormons Pentecostals Muslims
Jews and all it would take now is some
international Christ
we're people out of fear say you know
we've got to turn to God the world so
evil the world's perishing the natural
person they would look to to be sort of
the catalyst of world religions would be
Rome in spite of all the problems that
they've had with some of the impropriety
of the priests still Francis is
extremely popular while the priesthood
is not I I see that there may be an
effort in the last days to consolidate
these things and out of fear they'll
start forming kind of a one-world quasi
Christian religion they'll they'll say
oh yeah we're Christian but then they'll
be breaking the commandments in the same
breath alright well there's been no no
hidden secret that that the you know the
Catholicism heading of course Pope
Francis war I mean since back in the
eighties have pushed this and have
crushed the one-world religion and and
as you said a lot of Muslims really took
to Pope Francis a few weeks ago in the
summit and so that was a real you know
to the world oh that's a great
successful meeting coming together one
mind but well there's still there's
quite a rift in the Muslim world between
the Sunni and Shia Muslims I think the
Pope met with one sect and not the other
you know all of it would take now is
some for some terrible international
crisis or natural disaster or financial
implosion and and people are going to
start turning to God out of fear and I
can see where some of these leaders
would come together and say you know
they're probably not going to all
sacrifice every bit of independence but
they would consolidate out of fear and
then tell everyone else how they're
supposed to worship at the same time hey
thank you appreciate that David good
question and we do have a lesson called
one-world government mm-hmm I'm about to
send it out to anyone who calls and
asked talking about the one-world
government very interesting study makes
one of the we have is Robert listening
from college place Robert welcome to the
program thank you a happy birthday
pastor Doug well thank you so much
appreciate that you're welcome I wanted
to ask you um
you gave a sermon several months ago
about there is there's three times that
a person can say that they're saved I
guess once when when Jesus died we are
saved but then when we accept him were
saved and then when finally get to
heaven now I see I don't think we are
saved
just because Jesus died there's kind of
a universal belief there that Christ the
whole world was saved in him unless they
reject him it's almost like you know
after he died everyone was on the bus
and to be lost you have to get off the
bus I see I don't agree with that I
think that Jesus died to provide a bus
for people to be saved but they've got
to choose to get on it's like he gives
us a check but it does you no good
unless you cash it is that he does that
make sense yeah so he made a provision
for everybody
who would come to him that's why he says
whosoever will let him come but we must
choose to come and embrace the salvation
like the prodigal son father was there
waiting but he had to get up and come
home so you know we must we must choose
to come to Christ you know we do the
book called
assurance that I think you'd find
interesting wrong but it deals with this
very subject and we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls the number is 883
five six seven four seven and again just
ask - the book called assurance holiday
is listening from Baltimore pauletta
welcome to the program
hi pauletta are you there yes my
question is I was disobedient and
foolish and stupid and lack of knowledge
and God wanted to bless my life
financially and I didn't step out on
faith and I told someone and they
discouraged me make a long story short I
had been praying a prayer of restoration
the restitution with the small offices
have eight and may the Lord blessed me
to receive it back my question is I'm
praying and asking God to get it back
when Satan says the ones that comes kill
and destroy well are you talking about
getting back salvation
or was there an opportunity a financial
opportunity that you felt like you meant
financial opportunity you got it right
well first of all you can always pray
and say Lord I apologize for not having
wisdom and stepping out in faith
whatever that situation was you know you
know what that is I don't know and say
Lord would you please give me that
opportunity again now if you're
wondering does God give us second
chances
he gives us third and fourth chances God
gave Jonah an opportunity to to go on a
tour of Nineveh and he did not want to
go on that tour so he went on a
different tour and he was really sorry
that he went on the second tour through
the belly of the fish but after he got
out of the fish God says I'm gonna give
you another chance to go see Nineveh and
he said I'm going Lord so and God and
God does often give us second chances
you know and there are cases where we
missed opportunities and I know let me
give you an example there was a king in
the Bible I think his name was joram and
he was king of Israel Elijah the Prophet
was dying and joram came in and Elijah
the Prophet said take your arrows beat
the ground and joram hit the ground
three times and Elijah Elisha said you
should have hit the ground five or six
times he says the Syrians who've been
giving you a hard time the Syrians
you're gonna beat them in three battles
now but if you had beat the ground six
or seven times you would have defeated
them and so he got some of the
opportunity but some of it was forever
lost because he didn't step out at the
right time so timing is very important I
don't know what the particulars are and
you know of course you don't need to
tell me but God does he does give us
second chances you just ask him to open
those doors again and trust him in the
meantime
if you've made a mistake say Lord
forgive me if you'd give me another
chance I'll try to be faithful if he
does great if he doesn't still trust and
love him okay amen
thank you pauletta yeah we appreciate
your call I next color that we have is
Ron listening from Washington Ron
welcome to the program hello thank you
hey Ron we've got about a minute and a
half so I gotta make it quick yeah
to vote for our leaders Daniel 221 says
God puts meters up and takes him down
I've even heard it said that God gives
us the leaders we hear you and scroll a
lot for me well yeah you know I do
believe the Lord sets up leaders
sometimes the Lord uses us in a
democratic process to set them up but
you know ultimately these things are in
God's hands and it is true that people
often get the leaders they deserve I
don't know what we deserve as a country
right now I do think that God works
through natural consequences you know
the Lord establishes certain laws of
cause and effect and certain causes will
bring a certain effect and you know he
threw his guidance this country for
instance was set up with a democratic
process where we get to choose our
leaders if we neglect that freedom then
we're gonna suffer the consequences of
that and the Lord will allow sometimes a
tyrant or somebody to to be in position
by all means I think that God overrules
in the affairs of men Iran we thank you
very much for your call and apologize
friends we didn't get to your call
tonight God willing we'll be back again
next week give us another chance we want
to remind you again check out the
amazing facts website you're not only
fine we have a lot of material there at
amazing facts dot-com or amazing facts
dot o-r-g but you can go to our Bible
prophecy website which is Bible prophecy
truth com a lot of information there on
things happening in the world today god
bless you and keep us in your prayers
and keep us going
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic millville these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day amazingly imprinted
on the very fabric of time itself is a
24-hour period called the Sabbath that
was meant to forever be a time of
restoration for every human being a day
the entire world is largely forgotten
you'll be surprised to learn how this
special day of the Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit
AF bookstore com
what if you could know the future what
would you do what would you change to
see the future you must understand the
past Alexander the Great becomes king
when he's only 18 but he's a military
prodigy a hundred and fifty years in
advance Cyrus had been named Rahm was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined the Gospel writers see his
death as a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
Doug Batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time get your copy
today available now on DVD blu-ray or
USB for more information visit kingdoms
in time.com
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we build churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with a Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG
[Music]